100 years ago after the war our Founders
created a system they believed would
create lasting peace they divided
Society into five
factions everyone is tested to determine
who we are and where we
belong they call it
Divergent every everything we think of
that makes up a person thoughts
emotions history all wiped Away by
chemistry first is physical push your
bodies to the breaking
point only way you can survive is for
each of you playing your
right follow me today you will take a
test it will help you discover who you
truly
are we
to tr
yourself you have to be ready for
anything the future belongs to those who
know where they
belong
we
do the things that we
do the things